well our series a more perfect union
aims to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us just days before Christmas to
patience and dire circumstances at
University of Chicago Medicine forged an
unlikely friendship and made medical
history while doing it in interviews
you'll see first on CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz shows us how they formed an
unbreakable bond Adriana this has a
personal connection to it does be on a
good morning Daru Smith a truck driver
from the south side of Chicago was just
a few doors down from Sarah McFarlane an
occupational therapist from Michigan
they had different backgrounds but
shared the same grim odds they both
needed a procedure so rare it had only
been done 15 times in US history other
hospitals actually turned Sarah away and
one even suggested end-of-life care but
then she met Daru and their lives
changed course together at the
University of Chicago Medical Center you
wouldn't blame to Ruth Smith happy were
leukemia and Sarah McFarlane for keeping
their distance they were both on the
same wait list for the same rare triple
organ transplant I was like I don't want
to feel like it's a competition thing
like you know who's gonna live and who's
gonna die Daru has an inflammatory
condition that caused organ failure when
Sarah was a child a virus attacked her
heart and she had a heart transplant at
12 but recently her health deteriorated
both needed heart liver kidney
transplants but no hospital has ever
done two in a single year my mom and I
were both starting to get a little like
sad or doubt because they were telling
me that we need basically a miracle
doctors don't introduce patients on the
same wait list even if they have
different blood types like Sarah and
Daru but they met at physical therapy
and a friendship began I saw him going
to walk I was like oh I should really
get off and go do my laps - Sarah was
his marathon you know knocking out left
and she would encourage you me like you
know we got to do a we could slow down a
little
she was kind of like a coach yeah yeah
motivation I could job that positivity
paid off days before Christmas Daru had
a donor a new chance at life and to see
his three-year-old to grow up to be
honest I felt a little bad at first I
was like she also bent so much to you
know like why didn't she go first then
during darou surgery the transplant team
got news they could only describe as a
Christmas miracle Sarah got a match -
this is the first time it's happened
that one institution is doing in the
same year I'm not saying in the same
months I'm not saying in the same week
whenever in our dream thought it would
be so close Sarah how did you get the
news that you were gonna get
transplanted well so it was kind of
funny because dr. Smith came in of
course I knew who she met her time
because dr. Brian Smith is my fiancee I
said to her have you heard the great
news
and we were all like oh Drew's back like
it didn't take 20 hours so we just were
so excited kept talking for a minute or
so and I realized she had no idea the
good news for her exactly yeah so I
stopped her and said actually the donors
for you and she and mother were
speechless
we're like completely oblivious to it
for a long time and it's because of all
like the excitement from ourselves for
drew we have patients who have waited
two days dr. Volusion jeevanandham is
the pair's heart surgeon all told
Daru surgery took 17 hours Sarah's 20
almost back to back what do you think it
was that brought matches for both of
these patients in such a short amount of
time
it's one of those things about
transplant which is actually spiritual
you control some things but when donors
occur you have no control over at all
and maybe there is karma in that they
rewarded for their good deeds good deeds
like being open to friendship where
others wouldn't and paying it forward
I'm just very grateful for the decision
to be an organ donor out forever
take the gift cheers respect Oh usually
I don't
new year new me stuff but I could
honestly say this year like new year new
me
Giroux says he wants to change his life
and become a motivational speaker he
also looks forward to being able to
raise his son as for Sarah she wants to
live her life to the fullest to honor
her donor guru is still recovering in
the hospital Sarah got discharged on
Monday so she is off living that new
life what a great story and Sarah
lifelong friends so nice to meet dr.
Smith - dr. Smith is lovely I love it
that I swear you've got 160 thank you
this is a great store wonderful yeah and
if you have a story you think should be
highlighted in our series a more perfect
union we want to hear from you visit cBS
This Morning Calm to submit your idea